if you've been down in the dumps ever
since it was revealed that the upcoming
sixth season of history's drama series
Vikings would be its last it's time to
pick yourself back up a new Vikings
spin-off series has been announced and
soon Vikings Valhalla will be streaming
on Netflix but first a warning spoilers
for Vikings ahead before you start
scrolling through Netflix as thousands
of offerings looking for Valhalla know
this no release date has yet been
announced for the series considering
that the show's existence was only
confirmed to November 2019 Netflix is
likely nowhere near announcing a start
date for the series for comparison just
take a look at The Witcher that show was
first announced way back in May 2017 but
it wasn't until Halloween of 2019 two
and a half years later that Netflix
announced the release date that debut
date by the way was December 20th 2019
meaning it wasn't announced until less
than two months before the premiere
while Vikings Valhalla may not have
quite as long a wait given that it's
spinning off from a property instead of
building one from the ground up there's
no reason to believe that Netflix will
announce a release date for the show
anytime soon it's also worth mentioning
that since Vikings Valhalla is meant to
be a follow-up to Vikings fans won't see
it until after the original series ends
but forget about the question of when
you'll see it a better question is what
exactly is this spin-off going to be
about if there's one thing that Vikings
has been great at doing its killing off
its main characters season 3 saw the
deaths of Earl haraldson Swit ocg and
the priest
Athelstan Vikings season 4 knocked off
Ragnar second wife al slug his friend
and rival king Egbert and most
shockingly of all Ragnar himself through
up until that point had been the
series's main protagonist your father
was a great hero
perhaps the greatest hero of our race
all doctors live it on so just something
as more characters were added in season
5 the bodies continued to pile up with
seemingly no character being safe from
week to week
by the time Vikings concludes its run
it's possible that there won't even be
any Maine Vikings cast members left
alive to return for Valhalla and frankly
fans shouldn't expect there to be it has
been confirmed that the new series will
take place around a hundred years after
the current show meaning that even the
youngest Vikings characters will be dead
and gone by then instead Vikings
Valhalla will feature all new characters
based on even more historical figures
from Norse legend some of the main
characters in the new series will
reportedly be such legendary figures as
Leif Ericson Harald Hardrada William the
Conqueror and more even though the
hundred year time gap will make things
tricky alexander ludwig has suggested
that his character Bjorn Ironside may
not have finished his Vikings journey
whether that means some kind of
flashback sequence on the new spin-off
series or an appearance in a potential
feature film remains to be seen it's
just nice to know Ludwig isn't quite
ready to leave the world of Vikings
behind since the spin-off was announced
only recently plot details have been
scarce but that doesn't mean we can't
make a few educated guesses as to what
kinds of stories Vikings Valhalla will
be looking to tell since we know a few
of the main characters and to do that
we'll look to real Viking history Leif
Erikson is arguably the most famous of a
lot he has a pretty big claim to fame as
he's believed to be the first European
to discover North America rather than
that impostor Christopher Columbus
you're a phony hey everybody
this guy's a great big phony not only
that but Leif Erikson is said to have
done so a whole half millennium before
Columbus sailed the ocean blue setting
foot in a land he dubbed Finland back in
the 11th century next is Harald Hardrada
born about 45 years after Leif Ericson
he's regarded as the last great Viking
king having fought for control of Norway
and Denmark before meeting his end
during an invasion of England his
successor in some respects was his
contemporary the Norman King William the
Conqueror who wasn't a Viking but
claimed Viking ancestry is a descendant
of the one and only Rollo
William conquered England following
Harald hard radha's defeats becoming its
king the pair's respective battles will
almost certainly factor into the plots
of Vikings Valhalla
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]